hey I'm Alex and this is my recipe for
meatball stuffed garlic bread YUM
meatballs are one of my favorite foods
so I lived in Sweden for the meatballs
so you gonna start with making the
meatballs I did a classic ground beef no
fuss meatball but if you want to get a
little fancier here feel free to switch
it up it's been making these meatballs
because you need to stuff this into the
bread if you want to make them a little
bit smaller than maybe you would usually
make a meatball
some people wonder like how you're gonna
get like an even cook I'm using a
cast-iron pan to get a good sear which
makes it a little tricky but one tip is
to shake your pan and kind of fold them
around so that the meatballs roll while
they're cooking and get an even sear but
again this heavy pan it's not great for
rolling so I just use tongs and kind of
alright so once your meatballs are
cooked we're gonna move on to the bread
the second best part for this bread I'm
using a baguette so I cut the entire
baguette into quarters so I had four
pieces of bread that'll just make it
easier for you to be able to stuff each
piece evenly then you hole out the
middle of the bread or even say why
waste in the middle of the bread you
don't waste it you eat it you eat the
middle for the bread because arguably
the best part so once the bread is
hollowed out you're going to prepare the
stuffing so I did two pieces of
mozzarella and then two of those little
meatballs right on there and then you're
gonna wrap that up in like a little
cheese blanket so once your meatballs
are all wrapped up you're gonna stuff
that right into the bread cavity it may
be a little tricky to get in there but
just stuff it on it today the transfer
all those pieces of stuffed bread onto a
baking sheet and now I'm gonna brush
that some delicious garlic butter
that's the parsley in there a parmesan
and just take this thing to the next
level so brush that evenly onto the
bread it'll kind of ooze down and get in
those crevices and now it's time to make
so I wrap this loaf up in the foil so
that it kind of like in case everything
and made sure kind of all cooked inside
of the foil cut off Feeney and nice and
hot and then it's time to serve so I
serve this with marinara you could serve
it with that whatever you like
great party food cheese meatballs garlic
bread there's nothing better do you want
anything else let me know
find somebody else
[Music]